[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález el próximo 6 de
diciembre venezuela va a las urnas en
unos comicios atípicos y muy
cuestionados este proceso electoral
cuenta con el mayor número de aspirantes
a diputados de la historia de este país
veamos en total son 14 mil 400 que se
van a disputar también el número más
grande en cuanto a escaños son 277 un
total de 107 formaciones políticas'
postularon a algún candidato a una si el
proceso es señalado de ser fraudulento
irregular y deja más preguntas que
respuestas tanto así que la organización
de estados americanos la oea y también
la unión europea han adelantado que no
van a reconocer los comicios bajo el
argumento que es un proceso que no puede
ser visto como un proceso democrático
que propone entonces la oposición en
medio de la pandemia la crisis económica
la supervivencia del día a día de los
venezolanos y constante abstención que
ha sido demostrada en comicios
anteriores que piensan entonces estos 20
millones 700 mil veces
a los que están habilitados para votar
las elecciones parlamentarias en
venezuela es nuestro tema de debate hoy
en france 24 y para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a miriam kornblith ella
es directora senior para américa latina
y el caribe del national endowment for
democracy y también está con nosotros
aquiles este él es analista y consultor
en mercadeo electoral está en la ciudad
de miami en el estado de florida les
recuerdo que ustedes también pueden
hacer parte de esta conversación pueden
dejar todas sus preguntas y sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales se las recuerdo estamos en
facebook pero también nos encuentra en
instagram y en twitter como france24
santi logo la etiqueta de este programa
es numeral el debate efe 24 pues
comenzamos y comienzo entonces
preguntándole a miriam sobre el panorama
para ponernos en contexto el panorama
político que tiene venezuela en este
momento ya conocemos un poco la
situación que se está presentando allí
el tipo de gobierno que hay que hay un
gobierno interino reconocido por 50
países alrededor del mundo pero como es
el escenario político de esta selección
es atípica precisamente para ser
calificadas como atípicas miriam buenas
noches que tengan buenas noches muchas
gracias por la invitación es un gusto
estar en el programa bueno vamos a decir
venezuela ha tenido en desde la llegada
de hugo chávez al poder hasta la fecha
son un poquito más de 20 años en esos 20
años ha habido más de 20 procesos
electorales es decir la dinámica
electoral en venezuela es muy particular
y curiosamente a pesar de la existencia
y la ocurrencia mejor dicho de más de 20
procesos electorales lo que lo que ha
sucedido en el país es que hay cada vez
menos democracia es decir a diferencia
de lo que se espera y de lo que ocurre
el mayor país parte de los países
democráticos del mundo mientras más
elecciones más democracia en venezuela
ha ocurrido exactamente lo contrario y
este proceso electoral el venidero
proceso electoral las elecciones
legislativas
del 6 de diciembre son una vamos a decir
un despliegue más una vuelta de tuerca
más en este proceso de degradación
profundo de la grabación profunda de la
democracia en venezuela estas elecciones
son las que menos condiciones mínimas se
tienen para el ejercicio pleno de la
democracia es decir en este momento ni
las organizaciones ni las autoridades ni
los electores este
corresponden a un proceso electoral
íntegro libre transparente competitivo
soy de modo que bueno el proceso
electoral en sí pues es un reflejo de la
muy difícil situación política que tiene
el país y que además este como tú bien
ya los anuncios ideal vas en
venezuela a seguir una situación
irregular con un gobierno interino un
gobierno supuestamente establecido como
el de maduro que no ha reconocido ni
doméstica ni internacionalmente por
muchos sectores por otro lado venezuela
vive una gran tragedia ustedes en
colombia pues son testigos directos de
esa tragedia y más de un millón 700 mil
venezolanos en colombia en calidad de
refugiados
solo hay una tragedia humanitaria hay un
colapso masivo de todos los servicios
públicos de infraestructura de modo que
bueno el panorama crítico venezolano
ampliamente conocido y bueno
simplemente agregó que este proceso
electoral no es otra cosa que otro otro
aspecto más de ese decaimiento
generalizado mira usted ha dado buena
parte de los de los aspectos de este
panorama político allí en venezuela
aquí les complementamos entonces este
esta foto de esta panorámica de la
situación allí añadamos otros tipos de
complementos podremos añadir la crisis
también sanitaria por la pandemia
adelante
y volviendo al proceso del pse de
diciembre todo el mundo sabe que va a
ser un proceso totalmente fraudulento
nadie se chupa el dedo solo será
reconocido por los aliados tradicionales
del chavismo vale decir rusia-china
nicaragua cuba probablemente que los
rusia y algunos pocos países más que no
tiene ninguna calidad institucional la
gran pregunta si me permiten es que va a
pasar a partir del 13 de diciembre con
un interinato de el señor juan bueno que
perdería su curul en el parlamento
venezolano y por lo tanto quedaría
digamos en la lo que dicta la ley
fuera del poder esa es la gran pregunta
y a partir de ese de diciembre la
oposición ha salido al paso a esta
elección entre comillas sede siempre con
una llamada consulta que también pinta
muy mal las encuestas del día de hoy
refleja en que muy pocos electores irían
para presentarse a la llamada consulta
de modo que el panorama es muy sombrío y
de nuevo en la perspectiva para el
interinato de un juego pinta al mar
porque te daría si en el parlamento una
vez terminen las elecciones ya ha
llamado la tiranía de maduro aquiles ya
voy a tocar esos temas los tengo en mi
agenda esos dos puntos que usted ha
resaltado de esta consulta popular y el
papel de juan guaidó y que va a suceder
a partir del 6 de diciembre antes de
llegar a esos puntos y quería
preguntarles entonces quién va a votar
en estos comicios ya hemos visto en
comicios anteriores una muy baja
participación de los ciudadanos pero
vimos anuncios por ejemplo como el de
diosdado cabello en redes sociales
diciendo que el que no vota no come y
eso es una digámoslo una especie de
amenaza o tratando de hacer una pulla a
los ciudadanos en medio de esta crisis
económica para llamarlos a las a las
urnas y ejercer su derecho al voto
miriam cuál es su opinión sobre quiénes
son los que van a votar y quién va a
participar entonces
estos comicios para terminar de armar el
rompecabezas del panorama
y bueno esa es una importantísima
pregunta decir hoy en día los electores
en venezuela no están informados acerca
del proceso electoral están en cierta
medida bastante engañados porque se le
ha quitado las tarjetas y la personaría
jurídica a los partidos políticos
tradicionales no en realidad el elector
no sabe con qué se va a encontrar por
otro lado estamos en un medio de una
pandemia
y además a diferencia de muchos países
en américa latina y globalmente que
frente a la pandemia resolvieron aplazar
las elecciones postergarlas en venezuela
pues se está llevando a cabo un proceso
electoral en condiciones muy adversas y
más bien exponiendo a los electores
entonces la expectativa es que si nos
atenemos las encuestas hay una
abstención de alrededor del 70 quienes
hablan del 80 por ciento sin embargo
dada las características del proceso
electoral venezolano en el cual no hay
ningún tipo de certeza ningún tipo de
confianza ningún tipo de elemento que
permita
alguna contraloría básica alguna
transparencia una rendición de cuentas
básicas en realidad no sabremos cuántos
electores acudirán a este proceso
electoral es decir sabemos que en
venezuela en los últimos procesos
electorales pues el consejo nacional
electoral que es el órgano electoral del
gobierno pues puede perfectamente
fabricar unas cifras también así que en
el año 2017 las empresas smarmatic que
era la que llevaba adelante el aspecto
automatizado del proceso electoral
venezolano dijo que el cnt pues habían
anunciado un resultado electoral
con por lo menos un millón de electores
por encima de lo que ellos habían
reportado así que bueno y es posible que
no veamos nadie votando que haya muy
pocos electores en el proceso y sin
embargo las cifras oficiales pues
reporten cualquier volumen exagerado de
electores aquiles cuando uno mira los
procesos electorales en américa latina'
bueno en todo
países alrededor del mundo pues siempre
hay una fuerte posición por parte de la
oposición de los gobiernos de turno a
salir a votar a participar en los
comicios para dar una alternancia en el
poder digámoslo de alguna manera pero en
el caso de venezuela el escenario es muy
distinto porque la oposición
prácticamente no está representada en
este proceso electoral ha perdido fuerza
la oposición se ha fragmentado más de lo
que ya está cuál es el análisis que
usted puede hacer de los candidatos y de
las personas que están liderando la
oposición pero la oposición está sin
duda alguna en su momento más bajo de
escribí lidad frente a la población el
interinato digamos llegó al poder con la
oferta de remover a maduro del de
miraflores en la casa de gobierno en
caracas y ha sido totalmente ineficiente
a tales efectos
él se ha embarcado en su grupo de cuatro
partidos los cuatro partidos dominantes
en venezuela en una elección que han
llamado a la consulta un poco para
legitimar para darle más aire a la
operación del interinato pero como decía
más temprano las encuestas concretamente
una vez análisis una encuesta de una
empresa de medición de opinión pública
en venezuela ha dicho el día de ayer que
apenas un 14 un 15 por ciento de la
población iría a votar en esa consulta
esto refleja la falta de credibilidad
que tiene a la oposición en este minuto
está totalmente
desarticular en un archipiélago de
partidos y la población no está
intentando sobrevivir no le hacen mucho
caso a los llamados de la oposición
porque no ve no ve destino
ya los largos años que se saben
prácticamente que lleva un juego como
presidente interino entonces nuevamente
es una situación muy compleja y en
nuestra realidad porque la población no
ve credibilidad en la dirigencia
opositora miriam puedo hacer la ronda a
la inversa voy a continuar con aquiles
aquí vemos y seguimos hablando de la
oposición vemos unos aspectos
importantes la salida de leopoldo lópez
hacia españa
eso también bajó un poco la moral
digamos aquiles de los opositores y
también de las personas que siguen a
estos partidos de la oposición también
la incapacidad que ha tenido juan guaidó
para cumplir las promesas que hizo
cuando llegó a este gobierno interino y
un punto importante también es que esta
asamblea nacional que está
en manos de la oposición no ha podido
ejecutar ningún tipo de ley no ha podido
ejecutar ningún tipo de plan de gobierno
precisamente porque tiene a las
instituciones en su contra lideradas
desde los partidos del oficialismo y le
impide desarrollar sus planes y le
impidió hacerlo porque ya se le acabó el
tiempo para llevar a cabo un plan y no
lo logró hacer esto no desmoraliza aún
más a la oposición allí en venezuela
bueno sin duda alguna pero yo yo hago
una pequeña corrección respecto a lo que
usted dice ahora sobre las causas de por
qué la oposición acción efectiva a
efectos de desplazar del poder a maduro
a la oposición ya y esto no lo digo
nuestro de ser respetados medios
particularmente aquí en eeuu por sitios
en el new york times dice ha hablado
reportado de los casos de convivencia de
corrupción de miembros importantes de la
oposición entre ellos el propio acuerdo
el acuerdo lópez el respecto d
el gobierno del bufo de maduro entonces
yo creo que es una dirigencia corrompida
y una dirigencia que ha perdido la
oportunidad que no se vio en el espejo
en su momento para entender la
oportunidad de historia que tenía y
bueno mira ahora está enfrenta esta
situación de total de crédito y la mente
no cree en ellos es ciertamente bueno
todavía tiene el respaldo de más de 50
países pero esto es un respaldo que no
ha sido efectivo ha habido un cambio hay
un cambio de gobierno ahora aquí en los
estados unidos es incierto que va a ser
la administración país respecto a la
institución venezolana pero al interno
si les puedo garantizar que muchos
venezolanos pierden la esperanza al
menos la esperanza que había con la
presencia de gasto en el poder estable
de móvil la situación muy muy triste
miriam su opinión al respecto cómo
revertir esta fragmentación en la
oposición que no está representada en
estos comicios su líder más destacado
está fuera del país ya usted ya lo que
decía aquiles sobre el panorama que
tiene la oposición cómo poder revertir
eso de cara a unos futuros comicios
donde puedan tener mejores resultados en
primer lugar yo quisiera destacar que yo
no comparto las opiniones que ha
expresado a aquiles en realidad yo tengo
un altísimo respeto por la oposición
venezolana la oposición venezolana ha
aliviado a lo largo de estos 20 años en
condiciones sumamente adversas el
régimen inicialmente el régimen de
chávez ahora el régimen maduro
realmente ha cortado todo tipo de
libertad todo tipo de competencia todo
tipo de derechos mínimos ha irrespetado
las garantías para los ciudadanos para
los partidos para las organizaciones
destruido la institucionalidad y ha
generado condiciones sumamente adversas
para el ejercicio de la participación en
el ejercicio público y el ejercicio
político la oposición venezolana
realmente ha mantenido a lo largo de
todos estos 20 años la llama de la
libertad la llamada la democracia activa
y si bien ha cometido errores como
cualquier organización humana ha sido
mucho más el esfuerzo y el empeño por
mantener la democracia en venezuela si
la oposición venezolana en este momento
se encuentra una situación débil es
difícil no significa que no podrá
articularse hacia el futuro y no
significa que por ello vayamos a
condenar a todos los miembros de la
oposición como corruptos o o
malintencionado yo sinceramente
considero que si hay alguien corrupto o
malintencionado la oposición será una
minoría yo realmente tengo un gran
respeto por la mayor parte de los
líderes que las organizaciones y de la
sociedad civil democrática venezolana
que han dado un ejemplo muy
muy sólido de lucha democrática y la
receta sigue siendo la misma seguir
empeñados en mantener la democracia en
venezuela en organizarse en ampliar el
y coordinar al máximo con todas las
individualidades organizaciones
y expresiones tanto del mundo político
como el mundo partidista como en el
mundo de la sociedad civil articularse
con la comunidad internacional que no
creo que vaya a dejar de lado su alianza
o su apoyo a agua idoia lo que eso
significa porque él realmente pero desde
su perspectiva usted no ve que la subida
de juan guaidó no se ha debilitado a
nivel internacional no se ha debilitado
también al interior de venezuela
precisamente por esa capacidad de
inacción se esperaba mucho de él se
esperaba mucho de ese punto de unión de
la oposición que finalmente se pensaba
que ese eslabón iba a ser él
los resultados pues no han sido los
mejores sino yo estoy totalmente de
acuerdo se hace y se ha debilitado lo
cual no significa llamar a esa oposición
corrupta o indeseable o no sé qué
términos o sea si se ha debilitado pero
hay que examinar cuáles son las
condiciones en las cuales se ejerce el
juego político en venezuela y no creo
que ni siquiera podemos hablar de juego
el tema del terror político que existe
en venezuela ya no tengo ninguna duda
que esté la oposición venezolana aún
cuando está debilitada va a tener
capacidad de rearticularse de
reestructurarse de replantear
estrategias y creo que es necesario
además revisar estrategias realizar
planteamiento e incluso revisar la
composición del liderazgo pero no porque
considere que se trata de una imposición
una oposición indeseable sino que se
trata de una posición que está sufrieron
los avatares de un régimen y
clarísimamente autoritario si aquí les
hablemos de este 6 de diciembre lo que
va a pasar
de esa fecha de esos comicios y de ser
resultados ya lo decía yo en la
introducción que la oea y la unión
europea no reconoció en estos comicios
entra también otra vez esta disputa con
el otro organismo legislativo que ha
instaurado el oficialismo que es la
asamblea nacional constituyente o la
asamblea nacional alterna digámoslo así
a esta asamblea que es liderada por juan
guaidó entonces cómo va a ser esta
disputa internacional
esta disputa al interior de venezuela
por este organismo que va a ser elegido
a partir del 6 de diciembre quien va a
reconocer esto a nivel internacional
cómo va a tener este reconocimiento
dentro de venezuela el escenario
entonces se va a complicar muchísimo más
y un caldo muy complicado porque en
verdad son tres las instituciones
legislativas que hay ahora en venezuela
está la asamblea legítima nacional
dirigida por manuel o en principio está
la constituyente que ha dicho y está un
tercer parlamento
compuesto a medias por la
posición una posición nuevamente muy
corrupta que se prestó a los maneras al
gobierno y miembros de la de la tiranía
de maduro de modo que en la situación
hay tres parlamentos en venezuela no
solamente fundó la situación es muy
redada este pero yo quiero referirme muy
brevemente a lo que decía mi compañera
de padre política este las pruebas de
los vínculos de dirigentes
importantísimos de la oposición con los
llamados políticos empresarios puestos a
dedo y alimentados por el régimen
chavista están ampliamente reportados en
la prensa más seria del mundo
concretamente en 23 jon ayer y horta yo
no estoy inventando eso y la oposición
anda enfrascada en estos minutos a
precios de hoy en una operación de
cohabitación con el régimen esto lo ha
dicho de viva voz'
leopoldo lópez desde españa bueno todo
esto son cosas que sangre
y desprecio prácticamente que tiene la
población venezolana hacia sus
principales líderes opositores de modo
que estamos en situación desesperada y
la pregunta que yo haría es cómo hacemos
los venezolanos yo soy venezolano me
hago la pregunta como ciudadano cómo
hacemos para buscar un nuevo liderazgo
que tenga como eje fundamental la
liberación del país de esta tiranía y
nos sigue enfrascada en un juego del
juego político con una mafia que no que
nos da su brazo a torcer de modo que esa
pregunta que hace será conseguir con
seriedad porque a partir del 6 de
diciembre el señor juan ruido queda
fuera del poder al menos técnicamente
entonces hay que plantearse cuál es el
camino porvenir cómo va a ser la
relación con el principal socio de la
oposición venezolana al menos del
presidente muy bueno que ha sido estado
unido con bajo la administración baile
que ya ha dicho abiertamente que no va a
impulsar cambios de régimen en el mundo
entonces la situación hay que plantearla
con
serenidad y con mucha sinceridad bueno
usted que piensa entonces qué va a pasar
con juan baldo juan guaidó después del 6
de diciembre mira en un destino incierto
puede ir preso puede ir fuera del país
está mira está una extensión muy
complicada porque va a perder su puesto
en el parlamento venezolano y no queda
descargue no hay uno han dibujado una
estrategia lo único que han hecho es
llamar a una consulta popular donde la
gente iría
a firmar supuestamente que quieren la
ayuda internacional una serie de
preguntas que bueno que es la verdad no
hace falta hacer en venezuela y es un
cartucho que ya se ha quemado en el año
2016 se fue a una elección de este tipo
el 16 julio de esa face de ese año y la
gente ya se pronunció respecto de temas
que se volverían a preguntar en esta
oportunidad entonces no queda claro el
destino de cuál es el destino de la
dirigencia venezolana que a liderizado
el supuesto por ciento de liberación del
país
miriam hablemos de esa consulta popular
que hemos mencionado y que aquí les
estaba trayendo aquí a la mesa de debate
esta consulta impulsada por la oposición
liderada por juan guaidó lo hemos visto
incluso en buses en el centro de caracas
hablando sobre los puntos que van a ser
consultados qué opinión tiene usted al
respecto
siempre y por supuesto lo que quisiera
también remarcar al respecto de mi
comentario antena de la cabecera aquiles
es que yo distingo muy claramente entre
la oposición real legítima aquella que
no está convalidando el fraude electoral
y aquellos que se hacen llamar
opositores pero que están hoy en día en
este juego que han aceptado las reglas
de juego de maduro que se han prestado a
quitarle los nombres y los signos y la
personalidad jurídica a los partidos
políticos y que además han sido
identificados como por ejemplo alexa
el empresario barranquillero que hoy en
día está preso en cabo verde y que es
responsable de ver
la cleptocracia puede caracterizar
régimen venezolano y hago una distinción
muy grande y creo que hay que ser hay
que ser consistentes en digamos en la
diferenciación de digamos de ambos
grupos no considero oposición aquello
que hoy en día han entrado en ese
arreglo con el régimen claro respecto de
la consulta yo creo bueno si
efectivamente es parte del proceso
político actual la idea de la consulta
pues ha ido desde cuando se planteó
inicialmente no tuvo mayor arraigo diría
que hoy en día se está conociendo más es
posible que tenga un poquito más de
interés un poquito más de arraigo a mí
me parece muy interesante un artículo
que escribió hace poco el padre ugalde
que es una persona muy apreciada y muy
muy prestigiosa con podemos como una
vamos a dirigir una autoritas bastante
grande en el país él fue rector de la
universidad católica fue provincial de
los jesuitas una persona muy respetada
donde él mismo decía que él inicialmente
se había no sabía muy bien pues como y
no quería pronunciarse respecto de la
consulta pero que hoy en día él
considera que es muy importante que los
venezolanos quienes estén dispuestos a
participar y quienes estén dispuestos a
manifestarse le digan al mundo y se
digan entre sí que los venezolanos
hablen con los venezolanos que son
venezolanos hablemos con los venezolanos
y una manera de expresarnos es a través
de esa consulta es decir la consulta
obviamente no te no va a tener ninguna
repercusión ante cni ni va a mover al
gobierno pero es un mecanismo a través
del cual traer los venezolanos harán
expresarán su sentir y si lo han
expresado en el pasado eso no importa es
importante realmente ratificar una
visión si las preguntas en el 2017
miriam es debo avanzar con otros temas
se está extendiendo mucho y me quedan
pocos minutos para el programa aquí les
repito un poco esa pregunta que usted
estaba poniendo en la mesa de debate
sobre cómo generar nuevos liderazgos
dentro de la oposición allí en venezuela
cuál va a ser ese escenario posible que
articule a esos partidos en ese
archipiélago de partidos como usted
llamó a esas diferentes formaciones
políticas de la oposición porque puede
ser la única salida que tiene venezuela
generar nuevos liderazgos si una buena
pregunta yo creo que un futuro liderazgo
en venezuela un liderazgo político
tendrá que ver con aquel dirigente que
tenga la visión la energía para generar
una ruptura tanto con el régimen
con la oposición que está totalmente
desprestigiada el dirigente del grupo
político que tenga esa visión que tenga
esa energía que plantee la situación la
liberación de venezuela en términos
completamente nuevo de ruptura con las
fuerzas del régimen y con las fuerzas
corruptas desde la mayor parte de la
oposición esto lo digo esto los radios
contundentes
infelizmente así va a tener éxito en
venezuela porque el desprestigio las
funciones absolutos en el ferro casi
nadie los respeta este señor guaidó
perdió una oportunidad ahora que no se
va a repetir con un apoyo internacional
absolutamente único yo diría en la
historia del continente entonces
nuevamente yo creo que hay espacio para
que surja ese es el nuevo liderazgo la
población los va a apoyar los
venezolanos estamos cansados de admitir
alcanzado de mareo está
resulta así llamada no va a servir para
nada no tiene ningún carácter
vinculante- mire yo trabajo el mercado
político el mercado electoral todos los
días el voto es un intercambio de valor
uno nadie va a votar por nada es como si
uno fuera a comprar algo ese cartucho ya
lo quemó la oposición en una oportunidad
y en la población no los va a volver a
respaldar lo que no está adquiriendo
nada con ese voto y simplemente un gesto
opinión pública que va a caer en el
vacío entonces nuevamente
también está generando un paso más
profundo que es próspero para adquirir
turna un nuevo liderazgo opositor no a
lo que yo te tendería a apoyar en el
futuro me quedan llegar pocos minutos
para finalizar el programa y quiero que
hagamos entonces la conclusión de este
proceso electoral de este proceso de
voto muy criticado a nivel internacional
y criticado también al interior de
venezuela miriam su gran conclusión de
este debate y de este proceso de
elecciones parlamentarias en venezuela
muy puntual por favor
bueno creo que es la conclusión es el
proceso de líder o no cumple en absoluto
las condiciones mínimas de un proceso
electoral creo que fue una decisión
acertada de parte de la oposición de la
oposición verdadera no asistirá de ese
proceso y creo que a partir de enero una
vez que finalice esto pues habrá una
nueva oportunidad para rearticular a las
fuerzas democráticas y no tengo la menor
duda que en venezuela existe un profundo
profundo sentimiento democrático que
seguirá expresándose en la sociedad
venezolana no se ha rendido ante el
autoritarismo y esa es la fuerza seguirá
presente y manifestándose aquiles su
opinión su conclusión de este proceso y
de este debate bueno todos estamos de
acuerdo que lo desee diciendo en una
opereta
únicamente va a tener un beneficio nivel
en el beneficio es muy concreto va a
sincerar la situación del interinato o
acuerdo algo que ha sido totalmente
ineficaz excepto remover a modo del
poder yo creo que es en la única ventaja
visible que traerse de diciembre porque
la situación del gobierno interino hay
que sincerar la eso está completamente
agotado no tienen futuro y los
venezolanos tenemos que hacernos
preguntas sobre cómo vamos a salir de
leoni a efectivamente me alcanza para
hacerle una última pregunta miriam sobre
la mirada de la comunidad internacional
a este proceso en venezuela cómo van a
ver a venezuela a partir del 6 cuando
hay tres legislativos dos presidentes
sigue siendo una confusión toda la
política en este país que va a pasar
entonces desde la perspectiva
internacional
yo no llamaría confusión la comunidad
democrática internacional está muy clara
acerca de qué ocurre en venezuela
quiénes son los actores democráticos
quiénes no son la condena internacional
del de la comunidad democrática seguirá
tan firme o más firme aún de lo que
existe en el momento y este la
interlocución con los actores
democráticos seguirá de modo que yo
pienso que la comunidad democrática no
está confundida en absoluto ya quieren
su opinión
pues mira nuevamente tienes que
despejarse la situación del interinato
de aquí para adelante
viene un nuevo gobierno en los eeuu
el gobierno de dubai y la venezolana
ciertamente ya se han movido para hacer
lazos con la nueva administración bailén
pero no queda claro cuál es la política
que va a tener el nuevo gobierno hacia
venezuela el gobierno aquí en eeuu en la
gestión del presidente tronco respecto
de nuestra edad fue muy con trayectoria
eso también hay que ser muy franco este
durante los años de tron a pesar a las
sanciones las amenazas y la tiranía en
venezuela se consolidó y en el sentido
de que ser muy franco pero bueno mira
empieza el nuevo gobierno aquí en eeuu
buena parte de las personas que han
nombrado ya para el gabinete en mi
opinión es que tienen una visión clara
de lo que está pasando en venezuela la
gran duda si va a actuar de manera
contundente para remover del poder a un
régimen que es una amenaza a la
seguridad señor de los estados
pues a partir del 6 de diciembre
sabremos si todo este análisis es
concreto y es certero aquiles este ya
miriam complete muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en el debate de
france 24 ustedes también pueden
continuar dejando sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
de france 24 pueden seguir allí dejando
todos sus preguntas y comentarios porque
el player pues los estaremos
respondiendo más adelante también allí
en nuestras redes sociales sigan con
nuestra programación
[Música]